[Music]
round one action from the London chess
classic the last stop on the grand chest
tour the tournament started off with a
bang as 10 of the best players in the
world came looking to finish off the
season in style world number 3 Vladimir
Kramnik took on another former world
champion Veselin Topalov in what has
become a ritual grudge match and it was
the Russian who was able to dominate the
game from start to finish to take the
early lead in the event Britain's
Michael Adams had a fine position
against Levon Aronian from Armenia but a
sudden blunder in one move sent the
hometown favorite down in flames
Grantchester leader Wesley so took on
the birthday boy and fellow American
economy Mora but an inexplicable mistake
in the opening by naka gifted the point
to his main rival leaving a very happy
Wesley tied for first coming out the
gate the players have shaken off the
first round jitters and will now look to
uncork some brilliant moves round two
live from London coming up next